basically the the u.s. men's team got
golden Olivia it's the first time that's
actually happened since 1976 everyone so
quite a while so it's a big deal so what
I thought I'd do is because it's a
middlegame class I'd go over some of the
middle games from it and interestingly
enough I think that the match was
decided actually by what happened in the
middle name so it was like they knew I
was giving this lecture and they played
their games accordingly so I'll kind of
take the games one by one so basically
the first game on board one so we were
playing against Canada who actually had
a pretty tough team and their board one
is a player Guinea Barea who used to be
actually one of the top top 10 in the
worlds back in the late 90s but he's you
know he basically very rarely plays now
he's his ratings gone down but obviously
he's still a very classy player
apparently Canada is where Russian GM's
go when they're older and retired or
whatever but obviously still a very
capable player however I'd say that his
openings are probably not what they used
to be he used to be like almost
impenetrable in the French and CARICOM
systems probably not the case anymore
and of course Fabiano it was white and
he's extremely well prepared so Bernie
I've got a position which I'll be
generous and call it suspicious but okay
before we even continue from here what
do you guys think and one of the things
I do a lot when I lecture or when I
teach usually my students complain about
it is that I'm always asking what's
going on in the position to summarize
before we look for any moves so what's
going on here
yes
go ahead yeah
extra space I'm completely on board what
do you mean by more pieces more active
pieces I got you ah very good
the bishop yeah I mean the bishop on g4
the knight on d4 is a beauty Bishop on
g3 is actually kind of nice because it
can be offensive after f5 and holds the
position together so very nice
any other observations the rock on I had
to go to h6 in order to defend e6 and
even if it didn't I think castling
kingside looks a touch on the suicidal
side and he may live in Canada now but I
don't think that that's on his mind
so castling queenside definitely makes a
lot more sense
White's pawns are advanced over there
but it doesn't look easy for white to
open lines on the Queen side right and
it's pretty clear that White's idea is
mostly going to be centrally based yeah
it's very true and I like that you're
thinking about this position in a
positional way like if your opponent has
all pawns on light squares you want to
stick them with their light square
bishop and trade off their dark square
bishop right but the one thing I would
say is that you have to watch out for
this kind of thinking in the position
like this a position like this looks
very tactical right it's a mess you know
the pieces are kind of scattered
there's White's King is very open blacks
King is okay for now but could also be
opened up to remove like f5 it's a very
tactical position which means that the
fact that white you know the dark
squares could end up weak might be
meaningful later but you're probably not
gonna be thinking okay I want to trade
off this bishop and trade to an end game
and win because I have the dark squares
it's just it's so unlikely at this point
just because there are so many pieces on
the board and the game is so complex so
let's go forward so one of the
observations is definitely something
that Barea was looking for
he realized that okay my position is
really not so great if I just Castle or
play you know some kind of lame move I'm
gonna get hit with that five and
probably I'm just gonna lose so how did
he try to attack get counter play from
the black side what move comes to mind
yeah very good and that is indeed what
he played he's like all right it may
open up my King if I Castle over there
but I need to get my pieces out I need
to get my Queen out I need to make
White's King feel at least a little
insecure so he did this white took
obviously the knight on d4 is a beauty
doesn't want to move that anywhere so
tix he took with the Queen probably to
get out about five times so what now how
would you proceed
yes
now have you seen the game huh okay well
very good that like in each one
it's scared yeah it that it certainly is
and by the way it's okay to be scared
sometimes if you're never scared when
you play chess you're probably gonna get
checkmated a lot it's very true there
are some people who are never scared I
have a student like this well we'd be
playing he'll be like what do you mean
there's no danger I'm like okay we play
a few moves and his kings out on like E
5 and he's getting surrounded by pieces
he's like what's the problem I don't get
it and the whole point is that yes you
need us dead sense of danger now is
waiked King in danger just yet
probably not right but why would you
want to have your knight pin why would
you you know to rush with f5 here I
think would be a big mistake
and apparently Cara wanna subscribe to
your line of thinking because you did
play King no huge rush wow this is
really big fun I like this actually it
makes it three like what I wrote is like
really important all right so King h1
block castle he's like alright I'm out
of here
the strange thing is the Kings actually
not all that safe so what not
I believe one of you actually pointed
out this feature of the position earlier
in the lecture and now is your chance to
actually fix the problem with White's
position how could you improve White's
position well I'm glad we have an
indecisive moment now so we can all
choose between 93 and 92 what are the
features of each move where does the
night on 83 threaten to go he put he
chose d2 which I agree with because he
can threaten to go to d3 the knight can
go to f3 in some cases probably not now
but later and it's just you know it's a
more centralized square of course you
guys have heard of the role Knights in
the rim or dim that kind of thing and
sometimes it's not true but I'd say here
the net and a3 really is not impressive
but I like it on d2 a little better does
that make sense
already ninety-two finishing development
all right this is awesome okay so yeah
Queen takes c3 is not a good move
yeah just making sure you guys are awake
that's all I know this is too easy for
you all right so you don't want to give
up his queen this guy used to be top ten
in the world he's not gonna take on c3
so instead he played Rock h8 so now this
is kind of a thing that pondering h5s
getting hit who knows maybe eventually
those rooks will line up with the king
so this was actually the first really I
wouldn't call it a difficult move
necessarily but the first like real
important move which was really strong
that he found but in order to find this
move you have to really be looking at
the whole position and this is something
I like to encourage I think it's too
often people get too focused on where
they're playing like say you want to
attack the king you're focused only on
the Queen side and you miss something on
the on the Kings side for example or
you're trying to expand in the center
and miss that your king can get hit on
the h-file it's very common for Club
players to kind of just get too focused
on one side of the board or one part of
the board so looking globally is
something which in general
do pretty well and it's funny even if
you notice it when I walk around the
Chess Club and I'm looking at watching
people play their games very often
they'll be actually they'll even have
their eyes exactly pointed to one part
of the board
whereas when I'm playing a game I almost
never do that I'm almost always leaning
back sometimes I have a copy but the
main point is that I'm you know looking
at the whole board all the time and I
think that it's a good habit to get into
because if you don't look at the whole
board you'll often gonna miss some
detail in the position and in some cases
that detail is instrumental to playing
the position well or finding the proper
moves so look for any little detail you
can't have because this is something
that no one's pointed out yet I realize
this is a fairly quiet audience for the
most part but so the Ponte six is
definitely a weakness but it's not
immediately take a look no well c4
allows Queen takes d4 so it's probably
not bad Queen e1 so what are you what's
the point of Queen e1 so this was the
detail which I was talking about the
matter on h4 is really an awkward piece
and it and as Alex pointed out I mean it
if you attack it like where is it going
that is actually what happened so uh
yeah f5 is also a decent move by the way
but Queen e1 I think is even stronger
because now blacks really forced to take
on HP because if you don't take on h5
what are you doing Knight goes back to
five you just take it twice probably
with either pieces and it's just killing
keep in mind once the pawns are once the
Afeni pawns don't have anything in front
of them anymore they're just gonna start
rolling and by those tight at the time
those pawns get to e6 and f6 Black's
gonna be probably crying so it's
important that black not allow that it's
okay so black takes the pawn on h5 so
first of all I I definitely like what
you said about h-file the bishop on g3
may look kind of silly but it actually
is a very important piece because it
defends this pawn on h2 as long as this
bishops on g3 these piece these rooks
and all these pieces
kind of like Christmas ornaments they
don't really do much they look nice but
they're not doing anything because they
can't crack through on edge too so
taking on e6 is good however the way you
determine it the one phrase which I
really didn't like I hate to pick on you
for this but is it's great then I'll do
it all the time is that it looks
complicated like those left never ever a
reason to play a move unless maybe
you're dead lost and any attempt to
complicate the game makes it so you
don't lose this fast there are some
situations where you make that kind of
practical call here especially when you
think you're close to winning and you
know spoiler alert but white is
definitely winning here so you want to
make sure that you're calculating even
harder and this is again one of the
mistakes which I think that amateur
players tend to make and even players
who are masters and even strong masters
even I mean I certainly have made this
mistake many times which is that when
you have a winning position people tend
to kind of lacks off and not want to
calculate as much when you're winning
you actually need to calculate more
because usually what it means is that
you have to calculate tactics to win the
game if you're playing an opponent who's
just hanging their pieces and not
putting up any resistance there are
times when you can just roll over them
and not have to calculate anything I
would say that's a rare thing so when
you're but when you have a winning
position usually against a strong
opponent especially you have to
calculate a lot to find the win and to
force a win usually so in this position
if Carolina had been like well I don't
know 96 Bishop e6 they both look ok I'll
just pick one he probably would have you
know not chosen as well I guarantee you
he sat here for at least 10 minutes or
at least at some point maybe he did the
previous move and really calculated
really made sure which one was better so
why don't you guys do that now calculate
it not raise your hand
you'll get a chance to reveal your great
calculation later
now calculation doesn't mean calculating
deeply all the time sometimes it's just
one or two moves accurately and maybe
both captures are good this is another
thing that can happen so but okay I see
what you're saying I think that actually
both moves are completely winning there
are some cases where almost all your
moves are going to be good and sometimes
those cases are more are harder to play
than times when you have to find only
one continuation so what I would
recommend is try to find a crystal clear
win you know without it what allowing
his little play as possible and then you
know kind of just play it like you know
it you might have something the computer
says ah this is half a pawn better it's
plus four point five instead of plus
four doesn't really matter usually
usually what matters is that you
calculate well and that you find a good
so he chose Bishop takes c6 and I think
the simple reason is that he thought as
you did that the knight is great on d4
why would I move it you know so he he
really liked this Bishop takes c6 a
little bit better Knight takes I think
is a totally winning though cuz if if
Queen goes back I just bring the knight
back and I mean okay you can go to g6
but there's not there are no real
threats even if I take this bishop I
don't see how you're really doing
anything and I've just won a pawn for
free basically so this would also win
but the way he did it was nice because
now this Bishop on h5 doesn't really
make any sense right just kind of
sitting there all these pieces are
really funny but they're not really
doing much and meanwhile you're still
pinned the knight on d4 is still very
nice and it's just like nothing's gonna
go wrong with this and sometimes that's
the way you do it you think you're
totally winning
you calculate you make sure you're being
accurate but like what's gonna go wrong
here there's nothing even to look at
rook takes c6 Knight takes c6 there's no
discovery the net on D 2 covers f3 so
you don't have to worry about Bishop f3
incidentally that's maybe another reason
he chose the D 2 square to cover it
after and yeah from here on it was
pretty simple
he played Bishop back to e8 trying to
hold on for dear life
white advance the pumps and pretty soon
yeah I mean if black has to move every
piece to the back rank it's usually not
a good sign
rook f4 which was clever he wanted to
provoke this move in order to go back
now why would he do this
just looks kind of unnecessary right
like why are you provoking the pawn to
g5 you don't have to raise other
people's hands it's fine yeah mm-hmm so
now the E and F pawns are passed and
that's kind of what won in the game with
the pawn on g7 it was harder to advance
them so you provoked g5 and now he just
solidifies this position a little bit
start pushing and again he might have
had quicker wins here but it doesn't
matter right his main thing is he wants
everything defendant and he wants his
pawns to push and a couple moves later
and Bach decided this was enough so yeah
so f7 and now I mean it's just pretty
bad so that game I would say not a lot
of resistance by black I mean it was a
really tough position but his opening
position was pretty bad and then some
accurate middle gameplay notice the he
wasn't in a rush at first he played King
H 192 then Queen e1 was a really nice
move targeting the h4 Knight and then as
we saw you know blacks position just
totally fell apart life of course is not
always this easy especially when you're
playing on this kind of level so let's
look at a game where things were
actually not so simple at all so this
was Wesley Soze game against Alexander
listen again kind of a Canadian gem
who's definitely a strong player but
doesn't play very often so I guess again
it's like though all the players are
coming out of retirement for their
Olympiad apparently but he didn't have a
bad tournament at all he played very
well despite not playing very much so
they got to this position it was a
little bit interesting but okay so they
got here so I'm gonna do what I always
ask which is what
to summarize the position so what's
going on keep in mind even simple
observations can really be important to
any position claiming that White's
winning is pretty bold I would not agree
with that I think with best play maybe
why it's better but it's not it's not
super easy so why does have connected
passed pawns that's a definite advantage
this pawn on c4 could be a weakness if
it's if you're able to take it but it
could also be a strength potentially
right so pawns like this I'd say you
have to be wary of because they can
change over the course of the game for
now this pawn I would say is not super
strong but in a few moves it could
become a monster if it gets 2 C 3 and C
2 then you could really regret calling
this pawn weak so pawns like this you
have to be very careful of the connected
passers I'd say are also situational for
example if the bishop lands on d5 and
blockades those pawns are they really
that strong probably not but if those
pawns get rolling if black white can
play d5 d6 here or something like that
then it's you know could be just really
really bad for black so judgment matters
sometimes as much as calculating
properly does in a position like this
you have to realize that okay are these
pawns a strength or a weakness because
it varies it's not like connected past
pawns are always super strong sometimes
they just fall so you have to judge it
by a case-by-case basis so there are
actually two moves which I think should
be considered here and one I think is
definitely a stronger approach than the
other white could play d5 here trying to
advance the pawns trying to play either
takes the bishop or play d6 something
like this or white could play Knight to
d2 trying to target this c4 pawn and
claim that yes it is a weak pawn but
okay I mean from what I heard you guys
were saying well the pawns are strong
the pawns were overextended you don't
know until you calculate the only way
you're gonna know is by calculating so
as Alex pointed out very correctly d5 is
a mistake because after rook d8 d6 takes
takes Queen here and the pawn is the
pawn on c5 is gonna fall because y can
play Queen to d4 defending both the rook
and the pawn
but then rook c8 and the problem is that
yes your pawns are pretty they're moving
along but they don't have any friends
clean on d4 is the only thing that can
defend these pawns pawns need some
friends in order to survive in this
world
so this pawn the reason why this pawn is
to strength is because this bishop helps
defend it so but these two pawns are
just gonna drop and blacks gonna have a
significant advantage here you know why
can try taking this pawn but both these
pawns falling is gonna be a much bigger
deal that make sense so very nice um
which is why Wesley did not opt for that
one played ninety two as was suggested
so black with the couple options now I'm
actually curious why do you think b5 was
not played because it wasn't it creates
a connected pass pawn queen up three
looks like a reasonable move to me
I was thinking also ninety four might be
strong because I think if you come in to
d6 that nicest Knight is gonna be pretty
nasty also notice that white is the two
connected pastors whereas what black
only has a protected passed pawn so this
is where the doubled pawns are not
really that useful in the game so I
think that white would just be much
better here but I like your Queen f3
move a lot as well maybe it's even
stronger because now you're threatening
to play d5 d6 and here d5 d6 is quite
strong because you have three pawns that
are connected so black instead took the
pawn and played Queen before so what now
so what I would recommend is calculating
a little bit before you decide on a move
just just you know recommendation
because you have lots of options here
and it's probably important for example
Queen f3 defends the rook and puts the
Queen on a nice active square but then
maybe you have to deal with a move like
Bishop d5 hitting your Queen and if you
take the bishop than the rook has queen
c1 is possible trying to target the C
pawn but maybe black can try to target
the D pawn in response maybe you want to
move the rook but that could lead to c3
happening so you have to calculate you
have to figure these things out which
options make the most sense which ones
have the fewest draw bars and again as
was pointed out before there's no
substitute but to cap
okay so Knight to e4 is definitely a
possibility I like the fact that it
defends in attacks which I'm getting to
it
I see the move take it easy I like the
fact that this Knight defends the rook
on c3 and also attacks and it also opens
up the Queen so for example d5 is a
north however as was pointed out by two
very energetic young children f5 is a
possibility and one of the problems you
have now is because your rook is
defended only by the night if this
Knight gets attacked then there's a big
problem right because you have no way to
defend it you can throw in this check
but I play King g7 and now you have two
pieces attacked and I'm not exactly sure
you have a good solution to this problem
it may not be just dead lost right away
the King has to go to eight f6 to take
that night maybe the King will be
exposed but probably this isn't what
you're looking for right so and this is
something you have to be careful with
like if you defend a piece with a move
like ninety four you have to make sure
that Knight does not get attacked so any
other ideas
brookey threes a move so why did you
decide on e3 so you seem to be attracted
to this exchange set now exchange sexes
are a great thing to learn I would say
that it's a trick that you know strong
master players use all the time sacking
in exchange but you have to pick and
choose your moments here I wouldn't be
really like going out of my way to sack
on e6 if the need arises in some
positions it might be a great idea but
for the time being I don't see why I
should really want a sack in exchange
for that guy just yet
the bishop on e6 is nice it defends the
pawn but to go out on my way to sack for
it probably not
III is a pretty active square but I
wouldn't say it's even the most active
right now the rook hits the pawn on c4
which is a weakness the rook on e3 hits
the bishop on e6 which I would say is
not a weakness
so rookie 3 is definitely possible hmm
yeah that's very possible this move is
playable but again I mean I'd be worried
about c4 and even by the way if I play a
move like f5 it's not clear to me that
your rook is well placed here next I can
play c3 maybe I can play rook day to
maybe rook to d8 it's just not clear to
me you're doing anything too great here
so I like this Queen UPS to remove a lot
because it defends the rope but you're
also planning to maybe play rook F c1
and take this pawn maybe in some cases
you can take the pawn here and you also
have d5 ideas so black finds kind of an
interesting move with bishop defend so
now there's actually a dilemma there are
two main options and again it's not
clear which one is better because Queen
g3 is is a move but it's also not what
was played in the game and keep in mind
I mean Wesley so is you know 2780 so
he's a pretty good player at least so
maybe there's he found a move that's
worth considering 94 bishop takes e4 I
think you're gonna be in big trouble so
it's possible to take this bishop right
sacking the exchange which seems to be
something you like to do so what happens
after Queen take d5 incidentally Queen
g3 I think might even be slightly
stronger the idea being it's very simple
but the point is that next move you're
gonna be able to play rook b1 or rook c1
and then you have a powerful maneuver
which is the rook will move here and
this Knight which looks okay but you
might not be able to win this pawn out
right you can play Knight f1 to e3 and
then this bishops gonna be weak the
pawns weak you're ready to push your
pawns and that's probably very good so
there are times when actually the simple
solution is is a very nice way to play
Queen takes d5 though certainly is very
tempting and I have to say that if I
were playing white the likelihood I
would take this bishop is pretty high
because after Queen takes c3 why does a
very powerful move
very good Knight takes e4 would be a big
mistake because I know
Knight takes e4 would be a mistake
because there's rook a 4 and then
there's the knight new pause well rook
d8 96 so yeah and Queen takes e4 allows
Queen takes Knight
so 94 is very strong the idea being
nitrix f6 so blacks up the exchange but
blacks King is clearly quite weak here
so black played here white took this
pawn with check King AJ so he played
Knight d7
so he's attacking the rook this pawn is
gonna be weak as well and sometimes
Queen e5 check is gonna be very very
strong so black played Riki eight black
white brought the knight back to e5
double attacking the Queen in the pot
another strong but here black actually
has one clearly best move which stays in
the game without this move he should
probably be losing so the key is to find
the correct
and this is a very difficult question so
do take your time so I think that you
should move your queen
but the question is where and that is
exactly what black did unfortunately he
was not correct the Queen on he played
come back to f5 which is a very human
totally natural move the problem is that
white has two good options y can play
Knight takes f7 and back or what he did
in the game which was much simpler which
was just to just take this pawn so now
black has no counter play and white as
the zoo connected passes which ok the
game didn't actually go according to
plan quite yet but this should be good
enough in general I mean two connected
pastors and a knight compared to a rook
I would take the connected pastors in a
knight nine out of ten times you know
they're just I mean once the pawns get
farther advanced the rooks are just kind
of powerless now if the rooks are super
active it's a different matter or if the
pawns are weak as we've discussed but
for the moment I mean this is this
should just be winning so the key is can
black avoid this in any way black has a
very tricky movement and not only with
this moves strong objectively it
actually contains two or more traps rook
takes e5 yeah that would be good but
there's a problem
Queen's a say a Czech rather than taking
your rook and then I take the rope back
so I'm up a whole rook but I would say
that rook takes d5 Queen takes d5 check
probably this my PC pawn might be a
little quicker than yours but it's a
good idea I mean you don't want to be
bound to the idea if you have to move
your queen right sacking the exchange
back should always be on your mind so I
like that you were thinking on these
along these lines but I think that in
this particular case is just not not the
best move so yeah why Queen e2
well it takes over the night is check oh
I see yeah
yeah so very nice Queenie - so this is
the trick if Queen takes rook takes e5
the Queen's attacks and if trades you
win a whole piece if Knight takes as was
nicely pointed out Queen takes up one
check as a nasty shot because now if
King takes rook a one is mate yeah and
this is why you know by the way playing
for Queenie - it's not like you're
playing you know cheap chess all right
I'm gonna trick my opponent
sometimes when you're worse trying to
trick your opponent is actually the best
way to play but in this case it's not so
much a trap it's more that when you play
Queenie - you want your queen on the
most active square the Queen is best on
you - because the defense c4 hits the
rook and sets up this idea with rook
takes e5 so not only is it a tricky move
and your opponent could blunder but it's
a very strong move as well what I'd
avoid doing which I find again Club
players tend to do this a little too
much which is that they try to play four
tricks while worsening their position
they put pieces on bad squares to play
for tricks I would say this is a bad way
to do it however if you can put your
pieces on good squares and you can you
know play actively with your pieces and
still there's a trick it's kind of like
an added bonus to me now do I think
Wesley would have fallen for this no but
Queen e2 would definitely have taken
been a step closer to saving the game I
think the best way I can do now is take
the pawn and go back yeah going to d6
would be ill-advised so going back here
so now the rooks cut off so there's no
there's no meat if you take on everyone
but this position is just a mess because
now okay the white black King is
completely opened but this pawn could
become dangerous if it gets to c2 so
most likely I think the game would
actually end in perpetual with best play
I don't know exactly how it happened but
yeah so Queen e2 would have been a nice
fun but he played here Queen takes e4
and now you think okay well he's got
this now right it's not so easy so he
plays King g7
so in this I think it around here
Wesley starts to go straight now it's
moved 27 and a complex game it wouldn't
surprise me if some time pressure was
involved I would bet you almost anything
that black was in time pressure whether
white was in time pressure is another
matter I'm not sure but so the question
is how do you approach this position
what do you do well what it what exactly
is your main advantage here well none I
don't new fives kind of active the box
so what should be done with past pawns
yeah I have no idea what was wrong with
this move next you can play maybe rook
to c1 at some point place for c7 I think
these pawns are just going to become way
too strong and the next thing about
pushing pawns is sometimes it's a good
way to cut down a counter play because
if you push pawns what is your opponent
have to do they have to respond they
have to defend and if your opponent's
just kind of sitting there defending
against your pawns do you think they're
gonna be able to create any kind of
that's probably not right so sometimes
the best way to win cleanly to cut out
counter plays actually just to push your
extra pawns sometimes it goes a long way
the danger of course is that you
overextend or you don't play it quite
right and sometimes they can fall but as
long as the pawns remain defended and
remain strong I think that's just the
best way so c6 I think would have been
better he played Queen c3 which is kind
of tricky he might want to move his
knight and play d5 and try to take
advantage of the king but I think that's
a much trickier way to play
so black finds a nice move rook a to so
black is trying to get some kind of play
clearly and again I suspect that there
wasn't much time players like this of
course are very strong but they're still
human beings but definitely some
mistakes in happened now yeah here white
played route Knight d3 which I actually
think is a big error
and could have actually changed the game
in blacks favor the question is what
should you play here because that
positions changed now rook a 2 is a
really nice active move right and keep
in mind the Queen on c4 covered the a2
square which means that this move would
not have been possible
so something again I think that Wesley
could have just could have just pushed
but he got a
- attracted to this I don't know Queen
discovering the king thing it's actually
easy to do you can get lured into
playing moves like this because you're
like I'm gonna go for checkmate
sometimes this doesn't work but I'd
suspect he just miscalculated something
but we're not gonna do that obviously so
what are what can white do here hmm c6
is possible but here I'd say it's not so
clear because now I can put the rook
behind the pot the pot and that makes a
big difference right because now the
pawns can definitely become weak for
example next move maybe Queenie for I
might be able to just sack and try to
liquidate the pawns and draw that way
too so the pawns are not going to be
nearly as strong as with the Queen on c4
behind the pawns right that makes sense
so and I suspect the night c4 would lead
to similar problems that happen in the
game which I'll show you later but 94 I
don't think the right approach I
actually think this matter need 5 is a
very important piece any guesses why
very nice it blocks the rook on e8 from
getting in the game in the game black
could have gotten this rook in and
actually got taken the advantage so the
key is you want to keep this not any
five just to keep this rook out again
the Queen and rook may look kind of
annoying but just the two of them are
not going to create any massive threats
if this rook gets in and then there's
three pieces three heavy pieces aiming
at f2 it's gonna be an annoyance to say
the least
so Queen c4 going back haha so stops f6
gonna get the Queen to d5 this makes
sense so let's see probably I would play
rook c2 at I'm at Queen do you find this
looks playable
yeah I'm not exactly sure what black
should do but um maybe we're up b8 here
the problem is I have rook b1 in some
positions as well maybe not here cuz you
guard g2 but even just rook b2 so for
example c6 rook be - and now the pawn on
f2 is pretty weak and the problem is
again your pawn just can't go anywhere
because I kind of control all the
squares so it's a very it's a very
natural way to play the move I came up
with it was actually very strange it
whistle it was g4 okay but why g4
very nice and it's sometimes it's that
simple if Queenie for the rook can go to
e1 because there's no mate thread
anymore it looks like it opens up your
King but really your King was weak also
with the pawn and f2 right the queen
line of five was just such a perfect
piece so sometimes you just have to kick
it away shoo it away and then it's
actually not so easy actually after
Queen e4 there's also Queen b3 moves
with the rook and pawn turn f7 being hit
so there are lots of possibilities but
g4 actually was the only move that
really 93 was actually a big mistake and
why very nice and if d5 check f6 and the
problem is that even though these two
connected pawns look like they're just
gonna run the problem is that black can
play rook c2 rook d2 and notice how
black is the one with the active pieces
so even though you have two pawns
rolling up the board probably the rooks
are just gonna get behind them and take
them and White's gonna have a hard time
so you see how easily a game where it
look like wet and everything under
control right White had the Queen on c4
White was ready to push the pawns
everything was great but you allow your
opponent to activate their pieces just a
little bit it can turn the tide so
heavily because here I mean this
position just looks really annoying
cuz this rook has to stay on f1 because
they have to stuff the rooks are gonna
come behind these pawns are actually
just gonna be weak so this could have
actually cost the u.s. basically the
gold that we lost this match so and we
might have lost out on tiebreaks to rush
us or landed in the bronze so it could
have been that big of a swing not just
in the game but in the whole match to
give you an idea of the stresses of team
events imagine your coach has the
computer on watching this game going
like oh that's basically what a coach
does there so in this case for the men's
event
slenderman was the coach and and
Donaldson John Donaldson as usual was
the captain who handles the logistics
he's very very good at that
and for the women Robert Hess was the
coach and the captain was yeah so Sarah
so we had a lot of nice beat teams but
not just nice teams but very good people
backing them up so just to finish off
here black missed the chance and
remember you're playing an opponent
especially an opponent is strong it's
you're not gonna get many chances so he
played Queen to f6 which is not as
strong
Wesley kicked the roca way played 95-97
so here black got a little too
adventurous black probably was in time
pressure was panicking like I'm gonna
lose the game if these pawns start
rolling
so he's like take that looks like kind
of a nasty move right because if pawn
takes then there's mate Queen takes is
probably gonna lose all your pumps so
it's not such a easy situation but
Wesley doesn't panic it I've noticed
this is one of his strengths as a player
no matter how crazy the position is I
don't think his heart rate goes above 70
he's very very calm you know he might
look a little nervous sometimes but the
way he plays he never panics and I think
that's one of the things that makes him
so strong and it's a trait we should all
try to emulate I think he just does not
panic no matter how crazy things look so
he played his queen back to c1 pinning
the rook which I think was a nice move
yeah and here a black kind of went
astray I think that he didn't like his
position even here his positions not so
easy not so easy for white to just win
here anything like that h6 was a fine
move keeping the Queen defended so that
the rope can move so yeah h4 turned out
to be a good move but again getting in a
very tricky territory here play d5 and
here black just blundered you play Queen
e5
had he played rook d3 and played kind of
more normally I think this is not so
easy for white to win here in fact I
don't not even sure White's better
because again even though you have
interconnected passers which again as
I've told you the night into pawns I
take over the rook most of the time when
the pawns are rolling like this but in a
position where white that has the
passive rook black strokes are super
active not so easy so I'd say this
position is definitely you know would
have been okay for black but again I
think he just panicked and blundered he
played this move so the key is what
exactly is the blunder and by the way
the answer is not just oh he forgot his
rook was hanging if that was your answer
you can put your hand out but what's the
idea
after takes her up Queen g3 you're about
to get made it by the way if you take
that rook you better have in your mind
exactly why you're not getting made it
if you take the rook and then start
thinking we got a lot of problems Queen
I wanna yeah maybe six actually turns
out also be a good move but Queen a1 is
very nice so the idea is that after so
for example if King h7 what happens
correct
and if Queen King here
very nice by the way these are sometimes
the easiest moves to miss Queens it's a
really weird thing but long Queen moves
everyone can miss long Queen moves it's
easy to see like a rook moving for our
Bishop moving part but a queen moving
far just blows our minds for some reason
well that we see a long Queen move I
actually have this happen it was against
it was against a GM and it was like a
really complex position and I had this
move Queen h3 to a3 attacking an F a
rook and he can't defend it and that was
how the game ended and it was just I
mean this was a super strong player but
you know the long Queen move it's just
really hard to see to a3 yeah and if for
some reason it's just hard to see so you
have to sometimes put a neck strap in
and my guess would be that maybe he just
panicked and had no time it's very
possible um but yeah he may probably
miss that this Queen a one day a8 check
thing was possible but okay you're not
done yet
kingi soon 96 is possible you could also
play 98 and then and then after the King
moves probably say to g8 or f8 you play
Knight f6 check and it's over however
however if you wanted to be truly mean
to your opponent rather than make them
you could play this move and then the
Queen again proves that it's a long
distance piece
no it's not fair it really isn't
so after quit I won check black resign
okay so so basically the things to learn
from these games like okay the first
there were two very very different games
that happened in the same match right
the first game the the captain had to
really like watching that first game
Fabiana I've got a great position I the
opening just started you know play
everything was smooth he got his pieces
out Queen when t1 he was careful he
calculated properly but it was just a
smooth easy win
you know just based on his position this
game was not a smooth easy win he got a
decent position but you saw how crazy it
got but one of the key things that he
did well which his opponent didn't do as
well as he did was that he just remain
calm the win the position changed she
realized that he's like okay I have to
be careful now I have to change my
tactics I have to change my thinking but
one of the things you'll notice and this
is again something GM's do very well
particularly elite GM's
is that they don't if they make one
mistake
they don't make another right after it
if you watch games of you know like
sometimes lower rated players what
they'll do is if they make one mistake
they'll make another mistake they make
another mistake all in a row and it's
cuz they don't correct their thinking
after the first mistake once he saw that
the rook could get to e2 he was like oh
no I'm not allowing this night before
get your rook out this move get your
rook out and he immediately repaired his
position and even in time trouble he was
able to do this very effectively but
anyway I was quite quite a quite a cool
victor I did not stay up till 6 a.m. you
know get up at 2 a.m. stay up till 6
a.m. to see the end of the match I'm not
that addicted but but it was still I'm
sure it was a cool thing to witness and
again I mean it's it hasn't happened in
a long time so we had a very very strong
team this year I mean to have Wesley so
on board 3 is pretty impressive I don't
think most teams can have three top-10
players but it still never easy like
Russia always has an amazing team but
they sometimes struggle to win so the
fact that we were able to win was a
pretty cool game anyway any last
questions
yes that's a good question
to be perfectly honest sometimes the
answer is which players know the like
which coaches know the players better so
if a coat like if a player is known to
the players or coaches one that
sometimes it makes it easier but the
players vote on who the coaches so it's
always a player decision it's not always
unanimous just because you know not
everyone agrees but in this case
actually usually for the women I know
that it's usually melech goes and Yuri
Schulman
there are the two very common ones but I
think Yuri wasn't available or didn't
want to do it and Melek also had some
conflicts it was in Azerbaijan so he
couldn't break it so they had to choose
new people and they thought you know
Yasser and Robert have never done it and
they thought okay Robert would bring
some energy yasser brings an experience
it could be a good combo and the women
also had a pretty good event they were
very close couple results either way
they could have meddled for the men I'm
not really sure when you have players
this strong it feels kind of weird to
have like lender like Linderman's this
great player but is he like you know a
college strength no so it's it's kind of
difficult but usually they pick people
who know how to prepare very well like
they can prepare lots of lines and they
have like lots of knowledge about things
like that and then the captain like for
John Donaldson he doesn't really prepare
the players usually but he knows he's
great with logistics he knows all the
rest hotels he knows where to go for
restaurants he knows where the closest
rest rooms are to every place it's like
the guy just he's very detail-oriented